the city of harkiev looks battered and
bruised
every street in every neighborhood has
been touched by war
but there are some districts here that
have been blown to bits
at 8 15 in the morning a russian missile
sliced through the national institute
for public administration
its three-story reception hall was
reduced to a pile of dust
the fire department pulled one lifeless
body from the debris and said 11 others
had been injured
then they received a telephone call from
someone stuck under the rubble
they are digging furiously
some with spades some with their bare
hands but they've got so much work to do
there was a man in a crawl space encased
by bricks and concrete slabs
but a rescue worker called daniel
thought he knew where he was
[Music]
can
they use shovels and buckets and they
use their bare hands for it was well
below freezing and the rescuers knew the
man under the rubble wouldn't make it
through the night
but they've had little rest over the
past three weeks and the tension was
clear
give me a blade that cuts wood not a
blade that cuts metal said this rescuer
give me that one he begged
they worked under near constant shelling
with plumes of smoke marking the sky
the russian military says it doesn't
target towns and cities but the streets
of harkiev say otherwise
the sirens are going and
most of the search and rescue team
are heading for cover we're going to go
with them but there's still a few
people
the remains of the building trying to
get the man out
and a few minutes later a man called
vladislav was released from his tomb
how are
did you panic we asked
not really he said i was just trying to
protect my head
have you got anything to say to the
people who rescued you
what would you like thank you so much
[Music]
he is a fortunate man
for the search and rescue team are
needed in every single neighborhood
but when they heard vladislav's voice
they wouldn't give up for the man and
the city he lives in
john sparks sky news in harkev